NIGHT.
>> Tucker: I'M A PEACEMAKER.
>> Sean: RIGHT.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY," BREAKING
TONIGHT.
MAJOR SHOCKING NEW DETAIL
SURROUNDING THE
NONWHISTLE-BLOWER
WHISTLE-BLOWER, INCLUDING MORE
DAMNING EVIDENCE THAT HIS
ATTORNEY IS NOTHING MORE THAN A
DEEP STATE HATE TRUMP POLITICAL
HIT MAN, PLUS WE'LL ADDRESS THE
RADICAL SOCIALIST DEMOCRATS
RUNNING FOR THE WHITE HOUSE,
THIS IS IMPORTANT.
WE HAVEN'T BEEN PAYING ENOUGH
ATTENTION TO IT, THE GREAT ONE
MARK LEVIN, I JUST TALKED TO
THEM.
IF DON JR. HERE TONIGHT, IF YOU
MISSED "THE VIEW" TODAY, WOW, HE
CALLED OUT THE WHISTLE-BLOWER
HYPOCRISY, WILL GIVE YOU A QUICK
SNIPPET AND PLAY MORE LATER.
>> CHASING DOWN A WHISTLE-BLOWER
ABOUT ALL OF THE EPSTEIN STUFF
BECAUSE THOSE STORIES WERE
KILLED.
IF WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT
WHISTLE-BLOWERS -- YOU WORK WITH
CBS TO OUT THE WHISTLE-BLOWER.
>> Sean: THE LADIES OF THE
VIEW HAD A TOUGH DAY, WE'LL PLAY
MUCH MORE COMING UP LATER IN THE
PROGRAM.
WILL GET THE BEHIND-THE-SCENES
STORY, BUT START WITH BREAKING
NEW DEVELOPMENTS ABOUT THE
SO-CALLED ATTORNEY REPRESENTING
THE PHONY, NONWHISTLE-BLOWER
HEARSAY WHISTLE-BLOWER, HIS NAME
MARK IS
MARK ZS
MARK ZADE, HYPERPARTISAN,
DERANGED, TRUNCATING POLITICAL
OPERATIVE, HE HAS CLEARLY BEEN
PLOTTING IMPEACHMENT AND THIS
COUP FROM DAY ONE TREND, LOOK AT
YOUR SCREEN.
THANKS TO FoxNews.com, THIS IS
WHAT WE KNOW.
JANUARY 30TH 2017, THE PRESIDENT
HAS ONLY BEEN IN OFFICE TEN DAYS
AND GUESS WHAT?
HE TWEETED #Coup, AND HE KEPT
GOING THROUGHOUT THE YEAR
JULY 12017, TWEETING WE WILL GET
RID OF HIM AND THIS COUNTRY IS
STRONG ENOUGH TO SURVIVE EVEN
HIM AND HIS SUPPORTERS, WE HAVE
TO.
FOR MONTHS, HE TWEETED
INCESSANTLY ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S IMPEACHMENT,
COMPARISONS TO NIXON, TWEETS AND
FANTASIZING ABOUT LIFE AFTER THE
PRESIDENT BEING IMPEACHED, THERE
IS EVEN A TWEET HIGHLIGHTING HOW
FAKE NEWS CNN -- I PREDICT CNN
WILL PLAY A KEY ROLE IN
PRESIDENT TRUMP NOT FINISHING
OUT HIS TERM AS PRESIDENT.
IF HE HAS APPEARED ON FAKE NEWS
CNN A WHOPPING 11 TIMES SINCE HE
STARTED OBSESSING AND
FANTASIZING, IMPEACHMENT, AND
TWITTER.
HE GAVE US A STATEMENT SAYING
THOSE TWEETS WERE REFLECTIVE AND
REPEATED, THE SENTIMENTS OF
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE HE WAS
REFERRING TO A PERFECTLY LEGAL
PROCESS.
A REASONABLE IMPEACHMENT COUP
ATTEMPT, HE STARTED TEN DAYS
AFTER THE PRESIDENT WAS SWORN I
IN.
HE IS A SORT OF THE FACE OF THIS
TRUMP DERANGEMENT SYNDROME, LAST
NIGHT IN MONROE, LOUISIANA, THE
PRESIDENT HAD THIS TO SAY ABOUT
TEN DAYS INTO OFFICE IMPEACHMENT
MANIA.
>> THEY HAND ME THE STORY, THAT
WAS A LONG TIME AGO -- IT'S ALL
A HOAX.
THEY SAY JANUARY 2017, A COUP
HAS STARTED AND IMPEACHMENT WILL
FOLLOW.
IT'S ALL A HOAX, IT'S A SCAM.
ANOTHER WHISTLE-BLOWER, THE ONE
WHO CAME OUT WITH TRUMP SAID
THIS AND THE TRUMP SAID THAT AND
WHEN THEY HEARD THE REAL PHONE
CALL, THE WHISTLE-BLOWER
DISAPPEARED.
SHIFTY SCHIFF IS A CORRUPT
POLITICIAN, NOBODY THOUGHT IT
WAS GOING TO RELEASE THE PHONE
CALL.
>> Sean: AT THAT POINT THE
PRESIDENT IS RIGHT ON, THERE'S
QUID PRO QUO'S THE LIAR SCHIFF
WAS TELLING US.
IF HOUSE REPUBLICANS, GUESS
WHAT?
THEY ARE GOING TO SUBPOENA THE
NONWHISTLE-BLOWER WHISTLE-BLOWER
TO TESTIFY.
THEY PLAN TO CALL THE COMPROMIS
COMPROMISE, COWARD, CONGENITAL
LIAR SCHIFF TO TESTIFY UNDER
OATH.
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER AND HIS
HANDLER, THAT WOULD BE
ADAM SCHIFF AND PEOPLE IN HIS
OFFICE, THEY GOT TO ANSWER VERY
SERIOUS QUESTIONS -- THEY WILL
LAY OUT A FEW.
WE KNOW HIS OFFICE WAS IN
CONTACT WITH THE HEARSAY
WHISTLE-BLOWER BEFORE FILING THE
COMPLAINT.
DID SCHIFF COLLUDE WITH THE
ATTORNEY?
WHAT ROLE DID HIS OFFICE HAVE
BEEN ORCHESTRATING THE
COMPLAINT?
DID THEY RECOMMEND THE ATTORNEY?
THE NONWHISTLE-BLOWER IS A
DEEP STATE HOLDOVER FROM THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
TIES TO JOE BIDEN, LOOK AT
TONIGHT'S "WASHINGTON EXAMINER"
TONIGHT'S "WASHINGTON EXAMINER."
HE'S ACTUALLY A GUEST OF SLEEPY,
CREEPY, CRAZY JOE AT A LUNCH IN
2016 TO HONOR THE PRIME MINISTER
OF ITALY.
BY THE WAY, WHAT WAS THE
RELATIONSHIP TO JOHN BRENNAN?
NUMBER ONE TRUMP HATER OF THEM
ALL.
DID ANYONE FROM THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION ENCOURAGE HIM TO
FILE THIS COMPLAINT AND GET
INVOLVED IN THESE ACTIVITIES,
WHERE DID HE GET THE THIRDHAND
MATERIAL?
IT'S PERFECTLY OBVIOUS WHAT IS
GOING ON HERE, IT'S NOT OUR
FIRST RODEO.
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER IS NOT SOME
KIND OF CONCERNED GOVERNMENT
EMPLOYEE.
HE LOOKS VERY PARTISAN, HE LOOKS
LIKE A HACK WHO HIRED A HACK
PARTISAN DEMOCRAT HATE RAGE DROP
ATTORNEY WITH TIES TO BIDEN AND
WORKED FOR TRUMP HATER BRENNAN
AND OTHER TOP DEMOCRATS.
MAYBE THAT'S WHY HE HIRED THE
IMPEACHED TRUMP AFTER TEN DAYS
ATTORNEY TO BE HIS ATTORNEY,
MAYBE THAT'S WHY HE COORDINATED
WITH THE CONGENITAL LIAR, MAY BE
AND LIKELY THAT'S WHY HE AND
SCHIFF DESPERATELY DON'T WANT
HIM TO TESTIFY BECAUSE THEY
WOULD HAVE TO ANSWER THOSE
QUESTIONS.
THE CONGENITAL LIAR ADAM SCHIFF,
THREE YEARS OF LYING ABOUT TRUMP
AND RUSSIA.
HE'S NOT ON A FACT-FINDING
MISSION, HIS FIRST WITCH HUNT
FAILED AND NOW IT'S BECOME THE
SECOND WITCH HUNT.
THREE YEARS, LIES, RUSSIAN
COLLUSION, IMPEACHMENT.
EVEN IF THE SO-CALLED
WHISTLE-BLOWER WAS A REAL
WHISTLE-BLOWER, THE FACTS ARE
THE STATUTE PROTECTING ANONYMITY
DOESN'T EXIST.
HE IS PROTECTED AGAINST
RETRIBUTION, RETALIATION, NOBODY
GUARANTEED ANONYMITY IN THE
STATUTE.
THAT MEANS YOU BETTER NOT